the Joe Rogan experience you're like I'm
just not even this person where this
came from anymore yeah but Bill Cosby I
remembered him on that comedian
documentary saying that he writes a joke
and he adds like one word and then as
soon as it gets not funny he takes that
word out and goes back to like and but
he was also like raping everyone for
like many years so take him at his word
we were just talking about this that
some woman who's an attorney was saying
that he may very well be the biggest
serial rape or in history yes I mean I
don't know why I was excited about that
I know but it's goddamn crazy it's a
crazy
mr. vegetable and you know could it some
of those women possibly have died from
OD'ing oh sure I mean it's not like you
did a test on them to find out right
what life situation conditions they
might have oh yeah I mean who knows what
he's people have adverse reactions to
medication all that huh and back then it
was who knows what that's what was in
that stuff some women reported waking up
being they didn't know how many days had
passed they were dehydrated and disor I
mean they woke up near death you know so
I'm guessing he maybe it was you know I
wish she would tell the truth he won't
he's not I will but I wish she would
tell the truth like I would love if like
somewhat me he's so old now it's gonna
be really hard because I'm sure he
thinks about his legacy and he's
[ __ ] but I would love it if he could
just say like what what was going
through his head when he would drug them
like did he think they were beneath him
like what was it he had to have he had
to have I think it's a social celebrity
thing because he always exhibited the
weirdest parts of the celebrity
situation like he felt above people in
privilege I'll never forget he was
interviewing Ron Wanda Sykes interviewed
him at some awards show and he chastised
her for the way she was talking to him
and and he was wearing sunglasses inside
and he just had this arrogance about him
like here's Wanda Sykes was this
hilarious comedian and she's great he
should have been excited to talk to her
but instead he had this feeling that he
like this royalty and he didn't you know
it didn't appreciate her language or use
of language Wow he raped like 150 and
like like what in the [ __ ] but that that
sort of I am above everyone you know I
want worked at a casino and they told me
that he would eat dinner and he wanted
the entire staff in his dressing room to
watch him eat what yeah yeah yeah the
lady was really freaked out by it she
goes he would have the entire crew like
everyone door although everyone stand
there while he ate curry uh who'd eat
his food and then at night that was
actually more entertaining than the act
he was taking around at that time
because I fell asleep seeing him one
time which was ironic
I really I he came to my college and I
fell asleep this is why you're in school
though yeah but you're probably talking
over probably actually honest but he
watch crawl he also had the security
guard tuck you man
well they said he wanted the security
guard to tuck him into bed
and then shut the door and turn the
lights out I mean you must see this
though when people have seen that that
seems like super extreme
[Applause]